family forward the only book that I ever
read start to finish I read that after a
breakup in early two thousand two I'm
not a big reader mainly because i don't
have the attention span i start reading
a book extra mean I try to reboot my
book decision point and you know it's
hard for me to get through it I can't
sit still so I tend to like documentary
specials you know kind of give me just a
fast jack and so I can't sit still long
enough but that book was not too much
for me to absorb and the concept of it
is that if you're not failing you're not
growing don't be afraid to fail it's one
of the big things that prevent it is
even a model the same thing we're all
we've nobody wants to fail but the fact
of the matter is that when you fail you
learn something and so you learn what
not to do it says value is learning what
to do if everything you do always works
what do you do when something goes wrong
if anything you're better off with more
failures because you learn more from
failures than you do from success so
that book is close to my heart for that
reason because I I didn't know how to do
a lot of things so you just kind of move
forward whatever it is just move move in
the direction get closer to the target
and you know as you're negotiating I
talked about the minefield a lot some
nights you can see some you can't expect
to get hurt but that's okay because then
you can proceed more intelligently so
family is it's essential I don't think
any I don't think you can be a success
without how did your life change after
you finish the book
what was different I don't think that my
life it's not an instantaneous change
because you're still growing you're
still learning now that never stops but
it just helped adjust my my attitude
about failure but that doesn't mean that
I was less fearful of failing because we
all have insecurities I don't care what
anybody says everybody's got song
everybody's got their motives for doing
what they do or not doing and so the way
I see it you're not going to read a book
and have your life just change it's just
it helps you look at something that
you've always looked at in one way so
the devotee is sometimes that slight
difference in perspective is what you
need to get to the next step and if you
don't grow in adapt you'll just get
stuck it does step over and over and
over and over again just gonna be a bit
you have to do something different
otherwise we get the same result do you
think that makes someone more likable as
a talk show host as an artist if they
admit some of their short
instead of popping their chest out
making it seem like maybe it's like guys
at me I'm perfect I don't make any
mistakes okay of course because at the
end of the day you know yeah Lyle we
want about you know are being right or
whatever we want people to think we are
but we all know unlimited we all have
our little secret side that nobody knows
about sometimes even the people closest
to us and so when you admit an
imperfection or fear or failure there
are some that will jump on it and use
that as see see I told you they weren't
perfect but most people will find that
humanizing because they can relate say
oh you know I might disagree view about
this and that but you went through that
too oh now you now you're starting to
bridge the gap you find a common ground
and so I think it's essential for a good
talent maybe not necessarily you know a
singer because that's not their job
their job is to say but I think for a
politician I think it's important I
think for celebrity who's trying to win
people over maybe like a talk show host
I think it's it's important to but I
don't I don't know that you can say that
one is more successful than another
based on how many failures who are
willing to admit but I do think I'm gay
acknowledging your own imperfections is
it's not just good for your audience
it's good for yourself you don't to go
through this world thinking that you're
perfect cuz i got news for you you're
not neato
you